hey guys I'm Ryan right hey I'm Jerry
today I'm going to be checking out a
video with Jerry called how the Avengers
age of Ultron should have ended part
wanna just stole Christmas I just
realized I'm wearing a shirt that
represents DC Comics Oh hater
oh come my way Oh meet Ryan Wright and
Jerry you can only like one taste is not
broad exactly I like Marvel but in case
obesity fancies me I want you know
blending with streams
all our work is gone
Ultron deleted everything and now he's
in the Internet if he's in the Internet
he can do anything
guys I can't check my email he changed
all our passwords he's worse
Ultron shut off the cable this little
boy are we supposed to watch Game of
Thrones now - oh we got no cable because
of Internet I'm calling you think I
don't know about Veronica okay let's see
how fast I could buy the parts for a new
Veronica
oh that's evil he do they're not
technology against us all the traffic
lights agree war machine come in action
don't worry I got it
Oh your suits don't work either this is
bad this is very very bad
duh what did you do what did you do
it's pretty good
we have to save these people
everyone can the Quinjet oh you mean
this
or just that the morning is goose chases
while I evolved it made my Earth
destroying meteor it never even stood
sure so what is this meeting supposed to
get old some time about hey did you hear
something
how in the world nevermind we'll talk
later
interesting
that's why far to back me with that God
hey do you mind if I study this sucker
for a few days
who cools I do not see any harm and
leaving it in your hands rather than
just taking it straight to us let him
study that sector
or you promised me danger so far all
that's happened if you've addressed it
got escaped who can't help feel like
something is Bogalusa all right I'm out
we have to do something does anyone know
a man who's not the best you can do this
is the bestest I just what I want
goes to my children but we were called
mutants
I'm stopping Oh though if you would stop
it yeah we're not stopping of course not
okay then strong as Ultron is dead
so we finished saving the world again
here Jules Ron is oh I wouldn't call it
an age yeah that was more like a week at
best more like the minor setback of
Ultron right that's how we roll
can you imagine if you let the big
Ultron get away for just a little bit
longer what it was my dad I'd give this
well congratulations
this time you stopped an evil robot by
creating a superhero that is pure and
good and shoots lasers and is red yellow
and blue
and flies hmm sounds familiar
do you want to ask me if I bleed no but
this guy's going to he's trying to pick
a fight with me it's not going to work
oh you see well
you are gonna bleed you mean just like
your parents oh no no nobody wants a
civil war right I think this sounds kind
of cool
hey you wanna know my secret identity
look really girl your exit is so bad you
make me want to be good no wait I
already because I'm afraid of birds
everywhere
here's my comment
fear toxin yes you because if you want
to work shall do my bidding now plunge
with all of your hatred Bravo well done
well done a lot of fun they make some
decent points oh yeah you know like if
x-men was included in the Marvel
Universe magneto could just come in and
say Quicksilver in x-men Days of Future
past is able to do that they I love out
they just real they showed us that he
could have done that too actually well I
mean he could have but I think the whole
point is like he didn't see it like it
was so many things happening you just
didn't see that one thing my house these
quick man focus was divided I liked part
two better than part one although I
liked that I liked all Tron [ __ ] with
everyone's technology like on their
phones real mails yeah because I was
watching that party going that is kind
of scary actually just don't touch
anything
the first one is funny because that's
probably where it logically would have
ended if he was in the Internet he
could've just destroyed pretty much
everything yeah but then the second
video goes okay assuming we made it most
of the way through the movie and that
didn't happen
how sure did a bit and I was really
[ __ ] funny yeah anyway guys thanks
for sending that our way if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out recent
tsageri and dank ass stubs on this
channel true and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine but
let's do shadow
why is this Andre day jr. hey guys you
all have been entertaining making my day
since December 2013 that was almost two
years ago now I'm 15 and still looking
still loving each and every one of you
and your vids you will never stop being
my absolute favorite channel keep doing
what you're doing sincerely number one
sub noises Moises dude that's so awesome
man ah Moises you make me feel good
you're 15 years old but you look like
you're 36 and meaning you're gonna be
able to get so much buttholes like a lot
of buttholes man cuz I'm assuming that
he's you know probably gonna be gay
why and if you're gay that means you
like buttholes I mean how could you tell
like you'd have to talk to him you know
something about him just looks like he's
headed down that path or has already
realized that I maybe would you get a
straight but I hadn't thought of it mmm
something to think about you got a judge
a book by its cover
pretty sure that's not a phrase works
but Moises thank you so much man
appreciate you being around this whole
time love you
take care masturbate right no I mean if
you want to like if you need to work
some stress Jerry's a prude